hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast from history to action I'm
Judy O'Rourke of lab rats and I'll be
your moderator for today's event lab
rats calm is the leading scientific
social networking site and we're proud
to bring you this interactive virtual
meeting for more information visit us at
lab roots com here's how this
presentation works we want to hear from
you questions comments and even answers
can be submitted via the green Q&A
button at the lower left of your screen
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear or see this presentation
properly and let us know by clicking on
the support button at the top right or
the Q&A button and lower left this is an
educational virtual meeting and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the meeting is over please click
on the c/e button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your web page and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Bruce R Corfe md PhD dr.
cork is the Wayne H and Sarah Cruz
Finley chair and medical genetics
professor and chair of the department of
genetics director of the Heflin Center
for genomic Sciences at UAB and
co-director of the UAV Hudson alpha
Center for genomic medicine he's a
medical geneticist pediatrician and
child neurologist certified by the
American Board of Medical Genetics in
clinical genetics clinical cytogenetics
and clinical molecular genetics the
American Board of pediatrics and the
american board of psychiatry and
neurology in child neurology doctor corp
is past president of the association of
professors of human and medical genetics
past president of the American College
of medical genetics and genomics and
current president of the ACMG foundation
for genetic and genomic medicine his
complete bio is found on lab roots
website I will now turn it over to dr.
corfe for his presentation
production just trying to get my slides
to come up here we go first these are my
disclosures none of which have relevance
to the talk that i'll be giving this
morning so my job is to introduce the
concept of family history in the context
of genetic testing so will briefly
review the basic elements of family
history try to remind you of the major
patterns of genetic transmission then
talk about some of the risks benefits
and limitations that are relevant in
genetic testing emphasize the importance
of pre and post-test counseling and then
how the results could have implications
for other family members now one thing I
won't do is go into details of the nuts
and bolts of genetic testing itself and
I think this is something that will be
covered by other speakers and the course
of the day I'm going to begin with a
made-up case and actually you'll see
this case as a kind of thread through
the discussion over the course of the
next few minutes so this is a 38 year
old women Lois who's being seen for
routine GYN care and in the process
mentions that she's heard about
possibility of genetic risks for breast
cancer and is particularly concerned
because her sister actually was recently
diagnosed with breast cancer and
actually there are other relatives on
her father's side who have had breast or
ovarian cancer for that matter there's
also cancer on her mother's side so with
the family history and the fact that
she's heard about the possibility of
genetic testing she asks her
gynecologist whether this is something
that should be considered I'll have to
go back to very basic biology here for
just a moment to remind you of some sort
of fundamentals of human genetics
it begins with the fact that we're
diploid organisms that means we have two
copies of every chromosome except for
the sex chromosome so the non sex
chromosomes are called the autosomes and
you'll recall that females have two x's
and males have an x and y and if we kind
of zero in on any particular gene an
individual can have the same form of a
given gene on both copies of the
chromosome inherited from each parents
we call that that they would be
homozygous or the two copies may differ
in some way that we refer to as
heterozygous and the two individual
copies are referred to as alleles what
I've just described is the genotype the
particular form of the various alleles
given genetic locus and this in turn
might determine a phenotype in this case
for example blue eyes versus brown eyes
so the genotype infect informs the
phenotype so let me remind you all
briefly of the major patterns of genetic
transmission first autosomal recessive
in an autosomal recessive both alleles
need to be altered by some genetic
variation again we refer to that as
they're being homozygous and when an
individual is homozygous for a
pathogenic allele in this case little a
they would be affected by that condition
if they're heterozygous which is shown
in the middle on the left that
individual will not manifest the
phenotype because it requires both
alleles to carry the variant in order to
see a phenotype and of course if they're
homozygous for the unaltered version of
belial they will be unaffected so if you
look at the family tree on the right
remember that females are depicted as
circles males as squares the affected
child in the lower right is homozygous
for little a we indicate the phenotype
of the fact that the symbol is
is completely filled in there are two
siblings who are heterozygous and
therefore our carriers that are not
expected to be affected and then there's
a sibling also who inherits the dominant
non-effective allele from both parents
will also be unaffected and the parents
themselves are heterozygous carriers
unaffected with the phenotype in
contrast a dominant trait is one that
will be expressed either in the
heterozygous or homozygous form so big a
here shown as a red allele to indicate
that it would be associated with a
particular phenotype an individual can
be affected either in the homozygous or
the heterozygous form only the
homozygous for the little a unaffected
allele will have no phenotype at all so
if you look at the pedigree on the right
you'll notice heterozygous individuals
are shown is filled in phenotypically
affected they have a fifty percent
chance of transmitting the dominant
affected allele to any offspring doesn't
matter if it's a male or female who's
transmitting or for that matter a son or
a daughter who inherits the allele
notice that all of the affected
individuals in this family are
heterozygous none of them are homozygous
there are a few reasons for that one is
that if this is a rare allele it will be
a rare event for an individual to be
homozygous for the mutated or variant
dominant allele and actually in human
genetics it often turns out that the
homozygous for medically significant
pathogenic variants often is more
severely affected sometimes even so much
so as to be lethal well the third major
mode of transmission is X linkage this
refers to being low side that are on the
X chromosome so again remember males
have an X and Y therefore only a single
X and in a recessive trait shown at the
top where the male has the little a
variant allele he will be affected
because his Y chromosome doesn't have
a version of that allele for a female to
be affected by an x-linked recessive she
needs to be homozygous shown at the
lower right and that is going to be a
relatively rare event as compared to an
effective male so the most typical form
of transmission shown in the pedigree at
the right is carrier females who are
heterozygous have a fifty percent chance
of transmitting the allele to either
offspring if a male inherits it he is
likely to be affected if a female
inherits that she is going to be a
carrier depicted here by the little dot
in the symbols and a female therefore
has a fifty percent chance of
transmitting to a son who will be
affected and a fifty percent chance of
transmitting to a daughter will not be
affected the key in X linkage is you
never ever get mailed to male
transmission because of course males
transmit a wide to their sons and not
the X if a male is able to reproduce
which will be the case for many
excellent rates all of his daughters
will be affected because he has only
that single X chromosome to transmit so
in summary I won't meet all of this to
you but just remind you that an
autosomal recessive parents are carriers
sibs will be affected whereas a dominant
will be transmitted from generation to
generation and an x-linked recessive has
no male-to-male transmission with trait
being transmitted through carrier
females now this slide I don't intend to
narrate in any detail it is a summary of
the various pedigree symbols that are
used and you can refer to this later and
also there's a reference provided this
is based on standardized pedigree
nomenclature in the original references
shown at the very bottom let's go back
to our case now and so Louis is referred
to a genetic counselor and a detailed
family history has obtained concerning
cancer and it showed here in this slide
and
Louis is at the lower right let me see
if I can activate the pointer here and
there's Louis right there and her sister
is affected and very simple is filled in
in that sort of greenish color it's on
her father's side as you'll notice where
the other individuals with either breast
ovarian or I believe there's one
individual with prostate cancer are to
be found on the mother's side of the
family there also is cancer I'm in the
form of lung cancer or leukemia so a few
tips just to keep in the back of your
mind in terms of pedigree analysis well
before we do that I guess there's a
question that we're going to ask so let
me pause here and ask the question what
would you tell Louis based on this
family history either that she shouldn't
worry as the cancer is on the father
side on that there's perhaps not enough
risk of cancer to be concerned she
should consider being tested or she
should consider being tested for either
breast ovarian cancer or lung cancer so
let's take a moment let people indicate
their choices and then we'll move on
you
well this obviously wasn't too hard a
question so indeed there is significant
risk of hereditary breast ovarian cancer
here and we'll get to the fact that this
is on the father side but that really
doesn't change our counseling let me
just proceed with a few tips about
pedigree analysis we'll get to the at
the very end to kind of where this fits
into practice but you remember to ask
about deceased relatives people often
won't volunteer information about
relatives we're no longer alive you want
to ask about miscarriages or stillbirths
is relevant to know about ancestry often
individuals will have had multiple
partners that they won't remember to
mention if you don't ask consanguinity
and people being blood relatives is
important to consider and it's worth
considering to that people may actually
have a better success at assembling
family history prior to the visit so I
mentioned genetic counseling genetic
counselors will have completed a two
years master's degree program they're
certified by the American Board of
genetic counseling they tend to work in
all different settings prenatal
pediatric adult cancer genetics and
often in laboratories sometimes in
research contexts as well so the
counselor explains that the family
history indeed indicates an increased
risk of predatory breast ovarian cancer
genetic testing then can be arranged and
she explains the lowest the risks and
benefits of testing as well as the costs
and what the actual procedure would be
so what are some of the risks and
benefits of genetic testing among the
risks there may be anxiety associated
either with waiting for results or of
course with what the results indicate
there may be costs involved we'll talk a
bit more about that the possibility of
false-negative results again I'll talk
more about that or variants of unknown
significance and then read
related to cost of course insurance
issues when the positive side the
benefits could be information that
guides risk management particularly if
an individual that's positive and then
the peace of mind that may occur from
negative testing and of course the
results may have relevance not only to
individuals but to family members many
people are concerned that results of
genetic testing might put them at risk
of discrimination and you should know
that there is federal legislation in the
form of the Genetic Information
non-discrimination Act which prohibits
the use of genetic information that
includes even family history information
and the results of genetic testing
either for health insurance or
employment decisions it does not cover
long-term disability or life insurance
however and many states have additional
legislation in addition to this so I
mentioned the possibility of
false-negative results so that would
imply that an individual tested negative
but may still be at risk and what could
that occur a few possibilities are one
that there may be various different
genes that cause the same phenotype and
if you don't test the right genes then
your first not going to identify a
variant that could be relevant to an
individual's medical situation second in
some cases depending on what the
particular assay is that is used for
testing and the particular spectrum of
variants it's possible that not all
pathogenic variants may be detected by a
particular assay there are certain
assays for example that rely on
sequencing but might miss structural
changes in the gene and it's important
for the lab to have a pretty good handle
on what the sensitivity of their test is
and to be able to quote that and you may
find different labs will have different
test sensitivity depending on the
particular weight if they do the testing
the important point to remember is that
a negative result from genetic testing
may not eliminate all possibilities of
genetic risk there may be residual risk
so one should not walk away from
negative testing and assume that results
indicate that there is no risk
whatsoever and that residual risk will
be a very important part of both pretest
and post-test counseling and of course
non-genetic factors are not addressed by
genetic testing and there may be many
risk factors that account for whatever
is being tested for cancer in this case
but of course other things as well which
would not be addressed by genetic
testing the other point I mentioned as a
risk is that of a variant of unknown
significance and I find this is the
probably single most common source of
misinterpretation of genetic tests and
here the lab will return that a variant
is present but its pathogenicity is
unknown so what are the possibilities
here one is that it may be a benign
variant which means that yes it's a
variant something different than what is
typically seen in the gene at that
particular region of the gene but that
it has no significant impact on
phenotype and if you think of meeting
the genetic code almost like reading the
words of the book you could use the
metaphor that genetic testing is like
scanning a thousand-page book looking
for a typographical error and know that
there are examples where it could even
be alternative spellings of a word a
kind of a good example I think is the
word gray spelled GRA Y or gr ey you
would certainly have no trouble knowing
what the author meant to say regardless
of how that was spelt and so it is very
similar in the genetic code that there
are
examples of variants that are really
there but don't have any impact on
health in any matter and occasionally we
run across variants where we just can't
be sure whether this is or isn't
pathogenic it's possible that some of
these are rare pathogenic variants
haven't been seen before in the affected
population or in the general population
so how does one resolve whether a
variant of unknown significance is
pathogenic or not well one looks to see
if it's in population databases there
are many now where you can look and see
is this a variant that has been reported
before or not but you need to realize
that it is very possible that it hasn't
been reported before and is still benign
you can infer the expected effect on the
gene product that is is it likely to be
disruptive of the function of the gene
or not and there are various computer
programs that will do that and they're
very useful but at the same time you
need to remember they're just models and
so they don't guarantee that a result
that says pathogenic is going to be
pathogenic or the opposite we often look
for evolutionary conservation so if you
look at the particular variant and you
find that that base of the DNA sequence
has been conserved from humans down to
fruit flies or yeast even that implies
it's quite important and probably
variation at that site is not tolerated
because it wouldn't have been conserved
in evolution otherwise once again
something can be conserved but not
necessarily pathogenic so one shouldn't
view that as as proof of pathogenicity
but it's certainly useful a very useful
way to look at this is familial
segregation is everybody in the family
who's affected also found to be a
carrier of that variant and everybody in
the family was not affected not a
carrier even that's not infallible of
course if the family is small it may not
be enough people to test if it's a
condition it's only appear
in one generation that won't work but on
the other hand it can be a useful way of
at least helping to lend credence so
then finally other cases can be
extremely valuable if you find a variant
and it's been seen in 10 other people
with the same condition that gives you a
much higher level of confidence that
you're dealing with something that truly
is pathogenic but I make this point and
emphasize it in some detail because I
can't tell you how many people we have
seen in clinic who ended up having
genetic testing interpreted by a
clinician who was not sophisticated
about genetics and was told that they
actually have the condition because a
variant of unknown significance was
reported and then you see them sometimes
years later and realize that they've
been carrying a diagnosis that is
inappropriate so I guess the bottom line
is that if the lab reports a variant of
unknown significance what that is is
it's a variant of unknown significance
I'm not known to be pathogenic nor is it
proved to be non-pathogenic so it
shouldn't be used as a basis for
clinical decision making what about the
costs of testing well it's hard to give
a single answer here it varies with the
test including the complexity of that
test and the kind of volume you know if
it's a test that's done very frequently
with large volume their economies of
scale that may reduce the cost of
testing whereas a customized test we're
very rare trait might be fairly
expensive to do it obviously depends on
the lab and specific technology that
they use and then the question is this
covered by insurance and as with
anything else in medicine it depends on
what the specific policy is that an
individual is covered by and certainly a
wise thing before testing is sent to
explore what the actual coverage would
be for that individual even the same
company may have different policies that
are written for different people
depending on who's buying the coverage
different employers for example and what
might be covered by a given carrier for
one person might not be with another if
their policy was purchased with some
different mechanisms so really would be
very wise to check with each one some
companies will have specific conditions
under which a test would be covered
depends on what the degree of family
history is many actually require formal
genetic counseling before testing so
pre-authorization is really a very good
idea and it certainly may well be the
case that the patient may have a copay
that's not the thing you want to try to
figure out in advance because sometimes
the testing can be fairly expensive and
they could be surprised by a bill that
they're not expecting would emphasize
that this is a component of pretest
counseling done by a medical geneticist
or a genetic counselor so it really is
embedded in the process and a critical
part because the last thing you want is
to see the patient get a very large
unexpected bill on protesting that was
not described to them in detail before
it was done all right so we are going to
return now to this family history and
mrs. the family history as you remember
it and what was done here is that Louis
is sister with breast cancer was tested
first and she turned out to have a
mutation in the brca1 gene one of the
genes that predisposes to hereditary
breast and ovarian cancer and then Louis
is tested and her test turns out to be
negative which obviously is reassuring
to her so I think we have now another of
the polling questions so I'll pause and
let that be posted all right so why test
Lois's sister first so the rejoice is
offered her sister has better health
insurance testing is routinely covered
for those who have cancer
or if her sister is found to have a
pathogenic variant this informs Lois's
results so let's pause and register your
votes here
yeah I think we can take a look at the
results so most of you got what i think
is the right answer which is that the
result in the sister informs Lois's
result is testing meet new teen lee
covered for those with cancer and I
guess word routinely of course is a
loaded one but I think again this
depends very much on this specific
coverage so they just explain a little
bit more about the testing in the sister
and it's mentioned here in general I
think this could apply to almost any of
the testing we're talking about
certainly it's true for cancer genetic
testing if you can do it it's better to
begin testing with a known affected
individual so in this context we're
talking about testing motivated by
family history and if you can it's a
good idea to start the testing with the
sibling in this case or could have been
another relative and the reason why is
that remember I mentioned earlier the
possibility of false-negative results
there are many different genes and we
didn't talk about what specific set of
genes might have been offered for
testing in this case on very often
nowadays we use some panels of multiple
genes not just brca1 and 2 but many
others that predisposed to breast or
ovarian cancer but the key here is there
are many genes and we don't at this
moment know all of them and a negative
result in Louis if that's the only
person we had tested would leave us
unsure if we had covered the gene that
was relevant for her family whereas by
testing the sister and finding that she
indeed does have a brca1 mutation we can
rest comfortably then that that accounts
for the family history of breast and
ovarian cancer with very high
probability certainly it does in the
sister that implies that the father must
have been a carrier or at least was
probably a carrier based on
family history so negative result in
Lois is really reassuring but if we
didn't know that the family history was
accounted for by this particular variant
and we tested Louis and she was negative
there would always be a little bit of
uncertainty did we test the correct
genes and so here we can feel reasonably
comfortable that we did and that her
result really does indicate that she's
not at risk for the breast ovarian
cancer on her father's side of the
family so what difference does this make
you might ask does it help her and I can
say that when testing for risk of breast
and ovarian cancer was initiated which
was in the 90s not too long after the
genes were identified there was real
question as to because this really make
a difference does it change an
individual's outcome in some way to have
identified that they're at risk and you
know there was this perception well
maybe you've just told her the name of
the thing that she might or might not
develop but can you really do much for
her and I think over the years in this
screenshot of a paper from the New
England Journal of Medicine just one
example there really is overwhelming
evidence that there is a benefit to
testing in this case it could include
surveillance enhanced surveillance maybe
with MRI looking for a risk of cancer
surgery has been demonstrated to be an
effective way of mitigating risk of
breast and ovarian cancer that's the
point of this screenshot the individuals
at the top are those who underwent
surgery actually South Pingo Ophir
ectomy and had a much lower risk of
cancer than those were just observed by
surveillance which is the bottom curve
the farther down these curves goat
indicates individuals who develop cancer
so surgery can be an effective approach
there are chemo prevention approaches
and of course the impact of a test also
can include that you can provide genetic
counseling for the individual
and through their family one of the
questions that comes up is true children
be tested and family like this I'm now
Louis may be at risk of transmitting or
actually not Louis but another member of
her family I'm carries this could have
been at risk of transmitting the trade
tube child and should you test the
children for in this case risk of cancer
this has been thought about a fair bit
and the American College of medical
genetics and genomics and American
Academy of Pediatrics have issued policy
statements recently on this point in a
joint statement and the agreement in the
community has been that the preeminent
concern should be the best interests of
the child and in particular to offer
testing for children if the child will
realize clear medical benefits at that
point in time not in the future when
they're grown up but right then and
there and generally we would say that's
not the case say for risk of breast and
ovarian cancer this children do not
develop cancer due to any of the genes
known to be associated with this or at
least not the major ones like the brca1
and 2 and so in that case it's
recommended to wait until the child has
grown up and has chance to understand
risks and benefits of testing and make
their own decision about testing
although I will make the point that one
needs to remember that this is an issue
that the you need to ultimately be
counseled about now there are examples
of many genetic tests where it does
answer an important question for the
child that even includes some risks of
cancer certain genes associated with
cancer including some associated with
breast and ovarian cancer or lease
breast cancer especially could occur in
children and if those kinds of results
are found like p53 mutations for example
then you would actually offer testing at
a younger age because surveillance
actually might be relevant for certain
of these genes in childhood so it very
much depends on whether the child is
going to benefit in the immediate term
as opposed to whether we're dealing
specifically with adult-onset trace so
how does this all translate into
practice we often make the point of well
how useful a three generation pedigree
actually is I mean we wish that it would
be a routine part of care but the
reality is that it takes time to
generate a complete regeneration
pedigree and chances are pretty good
that in day-to-day practice it's not
going to be easy to assemble that kind
of thing now there are tools available
the surgeons general tool for example
which is publicly available and people
can be encouraged not to go online and
to develop their own family history that
way and it will help to guide them in
terms of for things they might want to
draw to the attention of their physician
but we realize that it's difficult to
fit a full three generation pedigree
into the very time constrained primary
care or even special specialty care
visits that typically occur but there
are some key questions that can be asked
that don't take very long can it least
be a kind of segue into on recognizing
relevant family history major medical
problems and first-degree relatives to
find as parents sibs or offspring early
deaths in the family due to disease that
is death at an early age or unexplained
sudden death would be some of the kind
of red flags that you'd want to be
paying attention to I'm a bit more on
red flags there are a set of conditions
or classes of condition really on where
you may discover things that could be of
great relevance on for the individual
health of your patient cancer we've
spent a fair bit of time on in this talk
today the kind of red flags here
our individuals with early onset cancer
earlier than what would be typical for
the general population for that
particular kind of cancer multifocal
cancer a person that gets a breast and
ovarian cancer or gets cancers in
multiple organs not due to metastasis
but due to independent primaries and
particularly be alert to breast ovarian
colon and thyroid cancers it's not a
complete list of cancers that are
associated with genetic risk by any
means but those are some of the major
ones for which testing is available so
these are the kind of signatures you
might say of hereditary risk of cancer
in the category of connective tissue
disorders a ortak to section or aneurysm
can have a genetic basis and genetic
testing for many of the forms that are
inherited can be available so that would
be worth asking about cardiomyopathy or
arrhythmia perhaps presenting a sudden
death often has a hereditary basis and
can be really life-saving to recognize
that risk in an individual and so as to
avoid the sort of unexpected event say
of an arrhythmia hyper excuse me
hypercholesterolemia I think a pretty
well-known risk factor for disease that
can be familial worth asking about and
we won't go into detail about
pharmacogenetics remember that there are
genetic variants that affect the way
drugs are metabolized they may cause
drugs to be metabolized unusually
rapidly which depending on whether the
metabolism in activates the drug or
activates it I will lead to aberrant
blood levels there are actually
genetically controlled reactions that
must occur to activate certain drugs so
there's a long list of these it's a
highly debated issue in terms of their
clinical utility and medical decision
making however i mentioned to hear that
are
important to know about malignant
hyperthermia is an aberrant response to
a specific combination of anesthetics
and actually it is routine for
anesthesiologists to ask about a family
history because that can be a
potentially life-threatening
complication of anesthesia whether it'll
come up in primary care I'm not so sure
but it certainly is part of the routine
questioning pre anesthesia and then
either stevens-johnson syndrome or toxic
epidermal necrolysis which is a
potentially life-threatening skin
reaction to certain medications there
are known to be some HLA alleles that
predisposed to this in Southeast Asia
and China it's actually become routine
to test for these that's not as
frequently done elsewhere in the world
because in that region of the world a
very specific HLA allele seems to
account for this risk and actually is
routinely tested in some answer in some
places rather and is been used to inform
who should get a drug that is known to
be a risk factor for this kind of
complication but in other parts of the
world it's a little more complicated in
the sense that no single wheel has a
high enough frequency to make it easy to
test for but certainly if it's in the
family history it would be highly
relevant because certain medications
carbamazepine just for one example but
many others could trigger this reaction
to individuals who are at risk well
finally let me just summarize and
emphasize that the family history can be
a really critical point of entry to
addressing genetic risks in particular
individual and you don't necessarily
need to take a complete three generation
family history I'm targeted questioning
can reveal some red flags that can be a
prelude to testing in many of these
cases then the follow-up is
genetic testing can be arranged to help
clarify risks that may lead to a
management program for that individual
and the ability to offer counseling to
other members of the family but that
genetic testing should be accompanied by
pre and post-test counseling and there
are medical professionals both genetic
counselors and medical geneticists who
are available to help with that process
I think this is the last slide in the
presentation and I know that we have a
few more minutes and I also know that
there is a a queue of questions so I'm
52 pause at this point and address some
of the questions that may have arisen
thank you dr. Kaur for that presentation
we want to get right to your questions
and input so here's a reminder of how to
connect with us questions etc can be
submitted via the Q&A button at the
lower left ok question from one of our
attendees have you handled controversial
variants that are reported as benign and
pathogenic by different teams there are
examples where particular variant
depending on what the data set may have
been may be interpreted as pathogenic by
summon perhaps not by others you know
here's for sure I think where it really
helps to have a genetic professional in
the loop and I think at least way I
handle this is to try to weigh the
evidence such as its presented and have
a conversation with the individual and
just lay out what we know and what we
don't know and no I think it's really
hard to answer that generically but it
tended to take the position that what we
really do need to give our patients as
much information as we have and the
reality is that
although sometimes the results can be
quite black and white they often or not
and we have to live at the fact that
sometimes there is ambiguity and
depending on what the evidence base is
give our best assessment and you know
there may be instances where we
ultimately have to leave the issue
unresolved at least at that moment in
time although there is the possibility
of further evidence occurring as time
passes that may further clarify the
issue what genetic testing should be
often teeny offered for
hypercholesterolemia I'm not gonna whoop
sick wasn't sure if I was okay yeah I'm
not going to get into the full details
of all the testing actually I wouldn't
claim to be an expert on
hypercholesterolemia testing my
background is more in pediatric
neurogenetics but there are sources of
information about genetic testing that
would be relevant to any particular
trait and I think some of the toolkit
that is provided as part of this series
can go into details their various
references gene reviews would be one
that I would recommend to go into full
detail about any particular form of
testing
what would you recommend to Louis if her
sister had not tested positive for brca1
so yeah it's a good question the issue
there you know of course it might well
have been more than just BRCA testing
that was offered so I would expect that
we would today do a panel of tests that
would have included a much larger number
of cancer predisposition tests that
could be offered so you know we would
have a real conversation about what the
implications are because you take the
point of view that most probably her
sister has whatever the trade is that
was segregating in was the father's side
of the family and that accounted for
risk I suppose it's possible that there
could have been a gene that was relevant
to other members of the family and you
know coincidentally her sister ended up
developing cancer for completely
unrelated reasons and meanwhile Louis in
principle could have inherited some risk
allele that other members of the family
carried and so you could therefore argue
that a negative test result in your
sister even if it was for a
comprehensive panel might have missed a
variant that other members of the family
carry and could have passed on so I know
we would have had a conversation about
that and realized that it was a I think
it reasonably high chance nothing would
be found if other members of the
father's family were available for
testing that could have been offered I
could imagine that we might still have
offered Louis a test but with a much you
know lower likelihood of finding
something that would be immediately
relevant and with a bit more ambiguity
attached to a negative result
lots of great questions coming in we
have time for just one more how do you
feel about the use of genetic testing
for disease risk in patients with no
personal history were adopted and have
no knowledge of their family history
right so I guess the question is an
individual who has no known family
history and is concerned about risk and
I guess it depends a little bit on the
context there so you know what weeds to
that concern about risk if it's the
occurrence of a sign or symptom in that
individual then you know certainly
testing would be indicated should an
adopted person be tested for you know
sort of a comprehensive panel of any of
the things for example that I spoke
about I guess right at this moment I
think that would not be sort of typical
practice because when you don't have a
kind of a prior probability of risk to
work with there's probably a greater
chance of finding variants of unknown
significance in a healthy individual who
happens to be adopted and leaving them
with ambiguity rather than clarity as to
what's going on there is a lot of debate
I can say in the community about the
value of testing individuals were
healthy for risks of actionable disease
that if you knew that they actually had
one of those risk factors might change
their management and you know the
discussions occur in the context for
example of direct-to-consumer testing
which is sort of an emerging area in
this discussions about population
screening for medically actionable
problems it is not a simple issue in my
judgment at least partly because of the
costs of testing all the various medical
follow-up that may ensue could chase
down variants we often won't know
what true penetrance is that is the
likelihood of disease when there's no
known family histories and you find a
variant but even if it's pathogenic how
sure are you that it will go on to cause
disease and finally the risks of as I
mentioned earlier variants of unknown
significance that create anxiety without
clarity so there's a lot of things that
come up in the context of testing
otherwise healthy individual you know
genetic testing tends to be at its best
when there is some significant prior
probability that motivates the testing
based on family history or based on
signs and symptoms and you're a much
more solid ground screening otherwise
healthy people of course it happens
routinely in newborn screening because
we have a lot of experience with how to
interpret results of how to verify them
and very significant medical actions
that can be taken it's a trickier area i
would say in healthy individual
screening and it's one of a very active
discussion in the community and it
wouldn't surprise me if over time we do
develop the ability to do that but I
don't think it's routine to do at this
moment I would like to once again thank
dr. cork for his presentation do you
have any final comments today
individuals speaking over the course of
the day we'll go into more detail about
specific conditions and specific risk
factors my purpose really was to use
this as an example to motivate the kind
of interest in family history and i also
would just highlight that a toolkit has
been provided that will help individuals
I'm go into more detail about many of
the things that you'll be hearing
through the course of the day I really
appreciate the interest that people are
showing in this and look forward to the
presentations to follow
thank you this is an educational virtual
meeting and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the meeting is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits you're also
invited to join dr. carp in the
networking lounge right after his shots
includes where he'll be answering more
questions just go to the meeting lobby
enter the networking lounge in lounge
there's a live chat feature where you
can type in your questions if you asked
a question this session it will not
transfer to the lamb so you will have to
reenter your query thank you for joining
us here at lab roots comms leading
scientific social networking site for
more information visit us at WWF com
today's virtual meeting will be
available for on-demand viewing on our
website through September 22nd 2016 will
let you know when it's been posted and
we hope you pass that information on to
any colleagues who couldn't take part in
today's broadcast see you next time bye